veteran presence over a decade
in the show wade miley and they
had a number of regulars of career worst
years swinging to miss by frazier
engine the fastball well located right
there
tom browning i see it
here's a tough dribbler barnhart spin
and the throwing off the helmet or at
least the runner
spikes down into the rolled up tarp and
out chuckle barnhout heart
bounced from behind the plate the gold
glover
you can see the throw and that runner
newman is definitely on the inside of
that line and that is so difficult to do
as a hitter
uses that 50 of the time to shorten it
picked
oh what a backhand with a broad smile
from hey eugenio suarez
love that short stop trevor kale on the
mountain
and that one is sucked tyler naquin
crushes
we just live in his world home run
did that ball leave the stadium
you see the change up right there left
it out over the plate
and i believe that ball did go out of
the stadium 454
feet at 113 and a half miles an hour
wow and cahill
strikes him out so the first time all
year that castianos has been struck out
but he relies heavily on that sinker
ball and he'll throw a little bit of a
hybrid between the slider and cutter
but he's a guy that's going to pound the
zone with a bunch of different pitches
part of the reason why he was pushed
back just a hair
elevated target here swing and a miss
that's the pirates bomber colin moran
well that's an easy fix
jim day don't let anybody get on base
don't have to go to the stretch right
exactly perfect solution
trevor cahill had his best big league
season
that one's poked over the ship shallow
ride
it's gonna get down base hit
bloop there it is mike mustakas a lead
off base runner
so it's important secondary leads being
heads up
mustache running here and there's
another blow up shallow center offered
and it's gonna get down the stock is
through second
takes third and if he's not ignited on
the pitch
i don't know that he gets to third base
the aggression pays off
ground ball base hit past the third
baseman gonzalez
bustaka scores and since ells into
second
on the rbi base hit by jonathan india
naquin holmard way out of here to right
field his first time up
that is sky that's got some carry
offered
in retreat for the bullpen again
back to back jacks for tyler nate
we're amazed at how good his hands were
well what does that mean his hand speed
his hands strength
and you can see right there the whipping
that bat
sal romano out there urging that ball to
carry
into the dugout and it does well when
miley gets going he looks like he is in
fast motion i mean he is ready to go
before he gets the ball back
popped up right side long run bottom
and he's there in time to make the catch
two down
i think you almost have to catch your
breath for wade miley lifted
high into the air on the right side of
the infield
and india will have it and that's a
three up three down third
of your muscles to create that swing
and he ropes this one into the corner
this will be extra bases for reynolds
it's a one-out double for brian reynolds
here in the fourth inning
swing in the miss three k's for miley
two have come at moran's expense
gregory polanco that broke his jaw
chopper to short
suarez has handled his position very
nimbly tonight
when you have a ball club that has
players that are capable and playing
well
when that ball gets away senzel can fly
he shoots up to
second moran just now gathers a stumble
over to third goes sinzell the throat
cut off
he takes two bags on one bad throw
in the air should be deep enough
let's see if they test reynolds since el
giving the go
the throw to the plate senzel easy slide
sac fly rbi six nothing
one out take a swing pitcher contact
base hit men at the corners
[Applause]
chopper misplayed by frazier
bobbled out at second and the lead man
barnhart able to come home a 7-0
reds edge you ask what do you do as a
hitter
you ask for timeout you step out
pace of play my way wade miley with four
k's in his third perfect inning jonathan
india
in hot pursuit of record-setting
territory
most hits with men in scoring position
by a rookie
in the first five team games since 1974
1-1 cracked on the ground past moran no
one home with the shift
suarez scores around a third mustache to
the plate to throw home
he's going to reverse course a head
first plunge back into the bag and
jonathan india stands alone
the sixth hit with men in prime real
estate
five ribbies tonight the most by reds
leadoff band since jesse winker
16th of june of 2019. i think their
humanity also
connects us and that one rips right
through
one run home barnhart given the way
reynolds from left concedes the score
one hop throw to second another two rbis
for tyler naked
[Applause]
and he's got another k
defoe goes down gawking sick five
strikeouts tonight
for miley you're playing or where you're
working if you get off to a good start
it gives you confidence in the long run
swing and a miss down on strikes brian
reynolds six
strikeouts for wade miley tonight he
scored
each time and that one is slug
center field a shallower playing default
has to retreat it's over his head it's
off the wall
senzel given the wave india through
second he'll challenge for three
zenzel scores throw to third no chance
helmet flies
india's safe the lots are flowing
and there's a good poke tucker barnhart
into the gap
india scores the hit parade continues
[Applause]
14 runs 17 hits tonight
ground ball shortstop suarez shovel
and the reds roll
bowl game reds as they punish the
pirates
the most lopsided victory for cincinnati
over pittsburgh
in over a quarter century